Hello everyone.
It's good to be here.
[BEEP]
Sorry, I guess I forgot
to turn off my phone.
But the good thing
is in [INAUDIBLE] we
have this nice
feature by which I
can put stuff in do not disturb.
So I think I'm
good, or so I think.
There you are.
It's good to be here.
Thanks.
For me, when I first heard about
this forum, I was very excited.
It's really nice
that we have a way
to connect with the web
developer community.
The web itself is something
near and dear to my heart.
I wouldn't have joined Google--
I was outside Google when
I saw Gmail getting
launched at that time.
And the fact you could write
an application like Gmail
in the web was an important
realization for me
for how important a role
our developer platform
was going to play in computing.
And we've come a long way.
But it's really exciting for
me to see all of you here,
and a way for us to connect
with the developer community.
The web is at an important
inflection point,
and I think
something in which it
will play even
stronger all over time.
When I look at mobile, it's
a very, very profound shift.
A few months ago I'd gone back
to India to launch Android One,
and seeing people come and
get their first ever computing
experience on a smartphone
is really amazing.
The PC throughout its life
cycle probably reached about 1.6
to 1.7 billion users.
Mobile is already beyond
that, just smartphones.
And in our lifetime
for sure it's
going to be the first computing
platform which will nearly
reach the entire world.
So we expect over 5 billion
people in the next few years
to have a smartphone connected.
And so to me, we haven't
lived through a phase
in which computing
reaches that many people.
So it's a really profound
shift, and so I'm
excited to see the
next wave and the role
that the web will
play in that paradigm.
We are seeing great traction.
We're deeply committed
to this area.
We're investing a lot.
You probably heard
from the team Chrome
on mobile has had over
400 million users.
And so for me, we feel a
huge sense of responsibility
in terms of making sure the
web evolves well on mobile.
And the web has such
unique properties,
and things which
make it particularly
good at what it does.
And I don't think we have seen
anything quite like it again.
So when I look at
how as a developer
you can write something,
it could be the long tail.
You could reach your users.
People can search for it.
People can find a link
in a social network,
get to your website.
And the model is simple.
It's universal,
and it just works.
There's no installs, downloads,
nothing to deal with.
And that model I think is
something really important
in computing, and it's
important to preserve that.
And to me, so I'm excited to see
what all we can do with mobile.
As a platform, the
work I've seen around--
be it focused on
performance around getting
60 frames per second,
be it to work offline
with service workers,
the Polymer stuff
so that you can build great
design with material design,
et cetera, really excites me.
And so hopefully we can
continue pushing all of that.
And especially when I use
the [INAUDIBLE], for me
I can see how interestingly
apps and the web and the browser
can all come together.
And we are in early
stages of this,
and the lines are blurring.
And so if you fast forward a
few years, I think hopefully
we surprise users and
all of us with the way
these things evolve.
And I think it's important
to keep an open mind.
And so don't have
much to say other
than this is an incredible time.
For me, the web
wouldn't be where
it is without
developers like you.
That's the crux of it in
the end, people building
great applications which really
advance the state of computing,
what users can do
with their devices.
And given what I talked about
earlier is an opportunity
to reach 5 billion
users, I think
that's one of the biggest
opportunities all of us
will see in our
lifetime in computing.
So hopefully you all
take advantage of that.
And with that, I want to say
thank you all for coming.
And you guys have a day
two tomorrow, so good luck.
And I'll see you guys soon.
[APPLAUSE]